Trascrizione: Manuela Serra
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Prendiamo un movimento semplice,
un movimento come questo.
Può essere un movimento per andare
a prendere un bicchiere d'acqua,
e quindi dipende da un bisogno
essenziale: la sete.
Però potrebbe essere anche un movimento
per prendere un bicchiere di vino,
il terzo bicchiere di vino
di una serata passata con amici.
E poi, magari, bisogna tornare a casa,
fare un pezzo di autostrada.
E su questa decisione, beh,
incombono le nostre conoscenze
sugli effetti dell'alcool -
la nostra genetica anche.
La propensione, quindi,
che sappiamo essere legata ad alcuni geni,
al rischio!
Anche i rapporti
inter-individuali che abbiamo,
in generale le nostre conoscenze,
e insomma la nostra personalità,
se vogliamo anche.
Ma fino a che punto
siamo condizionati da tutto questo?
Esiste qualcosa che poi ci dica
che siamo davvero liberi di decidere
se andare oppure no a prendere
'sto bicchiere di vino?
Come mai ne discutiamo adesso?
Ne discutiamo adesso
perché una serie di ricerche
hanno portato una serie
di neuroscienziati - e filosofi, anche -
a concludere che no: noi non siamo liberi,
che il libero arbitrio -
tema che ha attraversato la filosofia
fin dalla nascita direi,
del pensare dell'uomo -
ci porta a concludere che no,
che non siamo liberi.
Che è tutta un'illusione
quella che noi abbiamo di essere liberi.
E su che cosa si basa questa conclusione?
Si basa su una serie di esperimenti
che hanno tutti, grossomodo,
lo stesso schema,
anche se diversi modi
di registrare l'attività cerebrale.
Il più semplice,
che vi mostro più in dettaglio,
è questo che vedete qui:
c'è una persona che deve
schiacciare un pulsante,
e decide di schiacciare questo pulsante
quando pensa lui di farlo.
Non c'è nessun obbligo.
Deve soltanto prender nota,
in quel momento in cui decide
di schiacciare il pulsante,
di qual è il tempo su un cronometro -
oppure che cosa sta succedendo
in quel momento.
E mentre si effettua questa prova
si registrano delle attività cerebrali,
per esempio in questo modo,
con un elettroencefalogramma.
Ecco: quello che vedete
dallo schema  sotto
è che c'è un punto M,
che è quello in cui il soggetto
comincia a schiacciare il pulsante;
e c'è un momento D,
che è quello in cui decide
di schiacciare il pulsante.
E c'è un intervallo fra i due;
ma un intervallo molto più lungo c'è
nel momento in cui quella curva
comincia a salire.
E quella curva è l'attività
di preparazione del movimento.
Quindi è come se il cervello
sapesse prima di me,
che sto effettuando l'esame,
che cosa sto per fare.
E questo schema è stato ripetuto, anche,
con la risonanza magnetica funzionale
in cui si vedono qui le aree rosse -
le aree che sono connesse
alla attività di preparazione motoria -
e poi qui quelle in verde,
che invece vengono prima che il soggetto
abbia deciso di effettuare il movimento.
E in questo caso,
anche prima che abbia deciso di farlo
con la mano destra,
o con la mano sinistra.
C'è stato anche, poi,
una sequela di questo studio qua,
addirittura con registrazione
intracerebrale dell'attività.
Questi esperimenti possono
essere interpretati
anche in maniera diversa, io penso,
perché il cervello, in realtà,
ci informa spesso con ritardo
di quello che sta facendo.
Ad esempio, provate a fare
una cosa molto semplice:
toccarvi con la punta del dito
la punta del naso,
e puntate la vostra attenzione
sul momento in cui sentite la sensibilità
sulla punta del dito,
e sulla punta del naso.
Sono convinto che vi appare contemporaneo.
E invece,
l'impulso che arriva al cervello
dalla punta del naso
è molto precedente, di 250 millisecondi,
rispetto a quello che proviene
dalla punta del dito.
E questo potrebbe avvenire
anche nella preparazione motoria.
Perché no?
Noi, molte attività che facciamo
le facciamo automaticamente:
dal frenare improvvisamente
quando siamo in autostrada,
a anche attività più complesse.
L'osservazione dei pazienti
ci rende evidente
che questa dissociazione
fra attività volontaria
e attività, invece, automatica
è supportata, anche,
da diverse aree cerebrali.
Ad esempio, c'è una situazione
nella quale la persona non è in grado
di eseguire gesti semplici,
tipo per esempio soffiare,
ma li esegue se c'è un contesto adatto,
per esempio se le viene portata
davanti a una torta
in cui c'è una candelina,
e bisogna spegnerla.
Ma questo capita anche nel linguaggio.
Anche di fronte a una cosa
così complessa come il linguaggio,
le capacità automatiche rimangono
per parecchio tempo,
e anzi sono le prime che vengono salvate
anche in caso di un gravissimo
disturbo del linguaggio.
Ricordo un caso che non potrò dimenticare,
di fronte a una persona che aveva
un gravissimo disturbo del linguaggio,
nel senso che non era capace
di dire il suo nome,
ma neppure di dire il nome
di nessun oggetto di uso comune,
neppure di ripetere quello
che io le chiedevo di ripetere,
beh,  questa persona
aveva cominciato a poter contare:
quando io dicevo "uno",
lei diceva "due, tre";
ma poi si fermava lì.
E allora mi viene in mente di dire
"Signora, proviamo questo: Ave Maria -"
E lei attaccò:
"Grazia Plena, dominus tecum,
benedicta tui mulieribus, Benedictus -".
È una persona, tra l'altro,
che non aveva fatto
oltre la 5ª elementare,
ma evidentemente quella era una cosa
molto praticata, no?
La vicina di letto si alzò di scatto
e disse "Miracolo!".
Non era un miracolo.
Dovetti calmare un po'
gli astanti, diciamo.
Bene!
Sempre in ambito clinico,
quello che noi possiamo anche osservare
è un fenomeno veramente particolare,
quello del cosiddetto
all'arto alieno o arto anarchico,
cioè un braccio che fa quello
che noi non vorremmo che facesse.
Ad esempio, un caso che ho osservato:
una persona messa davanti da un libro
sfogliava le pagine di questo libro,
però le avevo detto:
"No, devi leggere quello che c'è scritto,
non devi sfogliare le pagine".
Lo sapeva, quindi, cosa doveva fare:
e allora con l'altra mano
andava a fermare,
a cercare di fermare la mano
che faceva questo gesto automatico.
Tornando poi al problema più in generale,
noi abbiamo delle decisioni che riguardano
delle discriminazioni percettive,
cioè ad esempio noi dobbiamo decidere
di attraversare la strada,
guardiamo a destra e a sinistra,
vediamo che sta arrivando un'automobile,
facciamo il calcolo
della velocità dell'automobile
e della nostra capacità
di andare velocemente dall'altra parte,
e decidiamo se attraversare
o non attraversare la strada.
E poi, però, ci sono altre decisioni
che vengono chiamate "economiche".
In realtà non c'entra,
necessariamente, anche un investimento:
ma sono tutte decisioni
in cui noi aspettiamo
di avere un ritorno positivo
in relazione al raggiungimento
di un obiettivo,
che può essere, per esempio,
una migliore salute
se decidiamo di smettere di fumare
e iniziare una dieta quel giorno stesso
perché staremo meglio,
o iniziare un programma di studi diverso.
Ecco, cosa hanno in comune
questo tipo di decisione?
Che francamente, è difficile pensare
che non siano libere,
e non siano il risultato
di quello che è la nostra personalità,
che ha certo dei condizionamenti
ma che alla fine ci lascia
uno spazio di libertà.
Tutte queste decisioni hanno in comune
il fatto di sorgere
dall'elemento responsabilità.
Responsabilità e libertà
sono strettamente connesse;
e in questo caso non è il cervello
dell'individuo, da solo,
che determina la capacità di scelta;
ma il fatto, quindi,
che il cervello di una persona
sia in relazione con gli altri
cervelli della sua comunità.
Ecco: allora, in questo caso,
in questo contesto
in cui c'è poco di automatico,
ma c'è molto di riflessione
sulla propria vita,
sulla vita degli altri
e su come la nostra vita
influenza la vita degli altri,
in questo noi davvero siamo liberi.
Ed è lì che si esercita la nostra libertà,
e il nostro libero arbitrio.
Grazie.
(Applausi)